who could have possibly foreseen
something going wrong with the Titan sub
well the lawyers that's who but will all
of this legal paperwork save Ocean Gate
the company from ruinous lawsuits and
will the estate to the victims be able
to recover anything well before the
Ocean Gate disaster CEO Stockton Rush
was bullish on the submersible that he
built to visit the Titanic he scoffed at
the complex navigation systems used by
other commercial Subs we only have one
button that's it this is to other
submersibles what the iPhone was to the
Blackbird Rush was proud that he patched
together off-the-shelf items from
Camping World and charged people 250 000
a piece to travel two miles under the
sea by taking off-the-shelf parts and
sort of macgyvering them together yeah
pretty much does that not raise
anybody's eyebrows in the industry oh
yeah
oh yeah yeah no I am definitely an
outlet and despite some obvious red
flags five people were willing to accept
extraordinary risks in order to see the
Titanic's ruins and they've now joined
the exclusive club that they were so
fascinated with and there's no question
that they knew that this was dangerous
they signed liability waivers that
warned them that the trip could expose
them to death now as many people assumed
everyone who paid to take the voyage
signed a waiver of liability with a
choice of law Clause the Ocean Gate
waiver that the passengers were required
to sign says the disputes would be
governed by the laws of the Bahamas
quote any disputes related to arising
from either the operation or this
release shall be governed by the laws of
the Bahamas Now the Bahamas judicial
system is based on English common law
and whether families can sue depends on
how the country handles liability
waivers the language of the waiver makes
it clear that the participants are
engaged in activity that could lead to
death quote this vessel will be subject
to extreme pressure and any failure of
the vessel while I am on board could
cause severe injury or death it
discloses that the Titan quote has not
been approved or certified by any
regulatory body and may be constructed
in materials that have not been widely
used in human occupied submersifals the
waiver says that support vehicles are
also not designed for passengers and
could become more dangerous in rough
seas and the waiver says that these
risks cannot be eliminated quote I
understand that such risks simply cannot
be eliminated from any operation the
risks include without limitation loss of
footing slips and falls on Deck
particularly in inclement weather harm
from falling objects on non-passenger
vessels drowning and malfunction or
failure of the submersible leading to
death or Serious injury and the
participants had to acknowledge the
statement as a condition of going on the
trip quote in signing this document I
acknowledge that if I die am hurt or
incur property damage during my
participation in the Expedition I may be
found by a court of law to have waived
my right to maintain a lawsuit now in
the U.S liability waivers only cover
ordinary negligence if a company is act
constitutes gross negligence or
intentional harm the liability waiver
just simply doesn't apply and here
ordinary negligence encompasses mistakes
due to to an attention or general
incompetence just simply to maintain
industry standards in contrast gross
negligence occurs when someone
purposefully fails to use reasonable
care to ensure someone's safety for
there to be gross negligence you need to
show that the defendant was more than
careless that they were Reckless and
engaged in behavior that might even
appear to be deliberate now the Hallmark
of gross negligence is that the
defendant showed a total lack of care
and disregard for the safety of others
and here that is definitely a distinct
possibility we'll talk about this in
detail later but here deep sea
exploration specialist Rob McCollum told
rush in writing before the disaster that
he sounded just like the makers of the
Titanic quote in your race to the
Titanic you are mirroring that famous
catch cry she is Unsinkable Rush emailed
him back saying quote we have heard the
baseless cries of you are going to kill
someone way too often I take this as a
serious personal insult but McCollum
wrote back to rush again in March of
2018 saying quote I think you are
potentially placing yourself and your
clients in a dangerous Dynamic who knew
knew how right he was going to be so
clearly at least one person thought that
Rush had a complete disregard for the
safety of other people though that was
an opinion that was shared by David
Lockridge a former employee of Ocean
Gate and the members of the Marine
technology society and when considering
whether there was gross negligence a
court considers whether a rational
person in the same situation would have
known that there was foreseeable harm
and Witnesses say that in the years
after Lockridge and McCullum issued
their warnings the Titan showed signs of
shoddy design the Titan was severely
damaged after it was struck by lightning
in 2018 Rush said that the lightning
strike damaged 70 of its internal
systems forcing the company to delay a
planned Voyage to the Titanic and that's
really just the tip of the iceberg
lightning can do weird things
um that pushed our uh testing
yeah back and we ended up having to
cancel that it was back in uh 2018. sub
expert Carl Stanley took a trip on board
the Titan in 2019 and reported hearing
cracking sounds in the hull and after
the trip Stanley emailed Rush with his
concerns at the carbon fiber Hull might
not be able to withstand the Deep Dives
in fact he wrote that during his trip it
quote sounded like a flaw defect in one
area being acted on by the tremendous
pressures and being crushed slash
damaged in 2020 the hull had to be
rebuilt because of the cyclic fatigue
that reduced its death rating to just
3000 meters which was well short of what
was needed to get to the Titanic and
both Lockridge and McCullum thought that
the window was a major mistake because
it would be exposed to around 6 000
pounds per square inch of water pressure
which is the equivalent of about two
tons of water at that depth however in
the summer of 2021 Rush told YouTuber
Alan Estrada that the window was made of
Plexiglas and that he was comfortable
with that because it was quote seven
inches thick and weighs 80 pounds and
acrylic is great because before it
cracks or fails it starts to crackle so
you get a huge warning if it's going to
fail and I'll let my friend over at real
engineering explain why this is Bonkers
an acoustic monitoring system like this
is akin to setting up a camera to warn
you thunder is coming you will see the
lightning before the Thunder but the
time between them is minimal so if the
window couldn't withstand the pressure
and the people in the sub could hear the
window cracking it's probably too late
the entire submersible was at risk of
imploding before it could surface and
several former passengers on the Titan
said that they thought it was completely
unsafe one passenger said that during
the Titan's descents and descent a
fluorescent glow stick was used instead
of the lights to save energy he compared
the Dives to writing in a quote car that
you drunkenly drove into the ocean
stared by a video game controller and
former passenger Arthur loibel said that
on his 2021 Voyage the bracket of the
stabilization tube which is the thing
that actually balances the sub Tor and
was hastily reattached with zip ties
Simpson's writer Mike Reese said that
communication failures happened on all
three of the Dives that he went on in
2022 but the problems continued also in
2022 the Titan lost control and started
spinning in circles at the bottom of the
Atlantic when it was just 3 100 meters
from the Titanic wreckage and something
happened to the thrusters that made the
Titan unable to move forward or
backwards and this Herring moment was
captured on a BBC documentary am I
spinning yeah
oh my God
and Scott is like oh no we have a
problem
I was thinking we're not gonna make it
we can't go anywhere but go in circles
uh YouTuber Jay Kohler took a trip on
the Titan just days before it's Doom
tripped and he said that the
communication system went down during a
routine test dive the trip was canceled
due to weather but Kohler felt like the
vessel might have imploded if the dive
had went ahead one of the passengers who
was killed in the Titan disaster was
Paul Enrique who was a Titanic expert he
had worked closely with the organization
that manages the Titanic wreckage site
and Jessica Sanders who heads the
Titanic organization said that she
regretted giving nargie Olay the green
light to go on the Expedition she said
that Russia had told potential
passengers that the Titan sub was quote
way safer than flying in a helicopter or
even scuba diving or even crossing the
street and note here that there's a big
conflict between what the waiver said
about the Expedition being dangerous and
deadly and what rush was confidently
telling potential passengers gross
negligence means that the person has
fallen so far below a reasonable
standard of care that their actions are
considered Reckless or even deliberate
so it's legally acceptable to engage in
how hazardous activities that doesn't
mean someone can't ignore obvious risks
so if Bohemian law upholds the liability
waivers it's likely the families will
pursue litigation in their respective
countries regardless of what the choice
of law provision says but that doesn't
mean that this would be an easy case to
bring because courts in many
jurisdictions tend to uphold liability
waivers if they are specific and this
one was very specific as a general rule
Claus's limiting liability are valid and
enforceable under common law unless they
violate public policy or the damage was
the result of willful or wanton conduct
on the part of the defendant some
jurisdictions have statutory exceptions
to this General principle generally a
pre-injury release will only be enforced
if in clear inconspicuous language it
explicitly indicates the intent to
release the provider from liability for
injury caused by that party's own
conduct or negligence each jurisdiction
applies different factors when assessing
a public policy exception but most of
them focus on two things if the the
terms of the waiver are clear and
unambiguous then a court first considers
whether the party being released
provides a necessity or other essential
service and second whether the agreement
is inherently fair and not
unconscionable risky recreational
activities like skydiving or scuba
diving are generally not public
Necessities or essential services so
when it comes to the first Factor courts
tend to favor the released parties when
it comes to the second Factor whether
the waiver is inherently Fair courts
weigh the respective bargaining powers
of the parties did one party have more
leverage than the other was the injured
party coerced into inherently risky
Behavior did the owner or operator
withhold information from the passengers
did the passengers understand how
hazardous the trip would be usually
liability waivers are presented to
something you have to sign or else you
can't participate in that activity some
courts find this problematic because
it's a take it or leave it proposition
and the participant doesn't have the
ability to negotiate but still more
courts conclude that if a person
voluntarily participates in an extreme
activity unequal bargaining power won't
actually invalidate the waiver so for
example courts have concluded that white
water rafting and skydiving are both
personal choices and not essential
services so there's no real bargaining
Advantage a person can't really be
compelled to participate in those
particular activities though there are
courts that view it differently the
Oregon Supreme Court for example found
that an unequivocal release signed by a
plaintiff injured in a snowboarding
accident violated public policy the
snowboarder could have avoided all the
risks by not using the defense facility
but the court still concluded that the
owner of the resort was in a superior
bargaining position because the
plaintiff had quote no meaningful
alternative to defendants take it or
leave it terms if he wanted to
participate in downhill snowboarding
though that is a minority position now
the thing about devastating injuries and
catastrophic events is that they can
happen at any time often without warning
so if you or a loved one is seriously
injured in a submarine accident or more
likely a car accident or a medical
malpractice accident or anything else
you can call my Law Firm the eagle team
we can help a free consultation is just
a phone call away and the link is in the
description now back to the submarine
Shenanigans though in an interesting
twist of fate uh lawyer David concannon
was scheduled to be on the Ocean Gate
Expedition but he actually canceled
because of a client matter can Canon is
an experienced diver who had been to the
Titanic before and he is listed as an
advisor to Ocean Gate he also has an
experience suing companies who are
engaged in hazardous underwater
operations even when the plaintiff
signed liability waivers and kincannon
actually settle the case against a dive
shop and the professional association of
diving instructors or Patty despite the
fact that the divers signed a liability
waiver and that shows us how Ocean Gate
might be liable if the applicable law
was similar to Montana's negligence law
when Linnea Mills died in a diving
accident in Glacier Park in 2020 her
family sued the dive shop Gull drive and
Patty for negligence wrongful death and
infliction of emotional distress Mills
was 18 years old when she signed up for
an advanced diving class the class was
supposed to cover situations like high
altitude diving and cold water diving
with dry suit however the instructors
didn't have a permit for the dive which
took place at the National Park after
the park had closed the dive shop
instructors were certified by Patty but
did not have much experience in the
diving situations that they were
supposed to be teaching and instructors
pressed forward with the dive without
doing a gear check they gave Mills a dry
suit without an inflated nose and she
also had a regulator unsuitable for cold
water use a GoPro video of one of the
other students showed Mills struggling
with the pressure in her suit when she
was 60 feet down and the video revealed
that Mills couldn't breathe and had too
much weight on her to actually Ascend
Mills was crushed by the pressure of the
water and this wasn't Gull dive's first
fatality in 2019 geldive rented scuba
equipment to a person not certified to
scuba dive and the man immediately
drowned upon entering the water gold
dive and Paddy argued that the
disclaimer formed that Mills signed
absolved them from liability however a
judge disagreed Montana's law allowed
waivers and releases to be enforceable
except when there was gross negligence
or defective equipment those things
can't be waived because Montana's law
quote does not preclude an action based
on the negligence of the provider if the
injury death or damage is not the result
of an inherent risk of these sport or
recreational opportunity when the judge
ruled that the case should go to trial
the defendant settled but of course the
Ocean Gate disaster didn't take place in
a lake in Montana it took place in the
middle of the Atlantic and when a
passenger or seat worker dies aboard a
ship family members can file a lawsuit
under the provisions of the death on the
high seas act known as Dosa that act
applies to cases involving vessels and
aircraft that go beyond the three
nautical mile limit off the coast of the
United States and its territories a
plaintiff has a cause of action if the
sea worker died due to an unseaworthy
vessel or through other provable
negligence on the part of the ship owner
the vessel in question must have been
engaged in what could be recognized as a
maritime activity and in addition to
Maritime employees Dosa also covers
civilian passages of a maritime vessel
to succeed in a dose Acclaim a plaintiff
has to prove that the vessel wasn't
seaworthy and a plaintiff can prove a
lack of seaworthiness if the vessel had
significant mechanical defects or was
otherwise incapable of hand handling the
situation such vessels could reasonably
be expected to encounter while at Sea a
plaintiff can also prove unsee
worthiness if the owner of the vessel
behaved negligently in connection with
their responsibilities as a ship owner
and here the facts suggest that Ocean
Gate may have reached its duty to
provide a seaworthy vessel for the crew
and passengers when Rush was developing
the Titan he started with an existing
vessel called the Cyclops one that was
constructed with engineers at the
University of Washington the engineers
used an off-brand PlayStation 3
controller to drive the sub however
Cyclops 1 was only Built to withstand
depths of 500 meters nevertheless Rush
decided to keep most of the design
elements of the Cyclops for the Titan
but engineered to go eight times deeper
when Rob McCollum visited the company
shop in Washington he thought the
PlayStation controller was ridiculous
quote and now you have the hand
controller talking to a Wi-Fi unit which
is talking to a black box which is
talking to the subs thrusters there were
multiple points of failure Rush said
that the whole com system ran on
Bluetooth and Rush ignored all the
feedback and it in particular he decided
that the Titan's cylindrical midsection
would be made of carbon fiber instead of
titanium carbon fiber is a great
material it's better than titanium it's
better than a lot of other materials the
Titan was completed in 2018 but experts
had concerns about whether the sub could
withstand the rigors of deep sea
exploration my friend over at real
engineering explained why carbon fiber
was a problematic Choice carbon fiber
Composites aren't really known for their
compressive strength they work best in
tension great for airplanes that are
pressurized from the inside where the
pressure inside the fuselage Works to
expand the circular cross-section
putting the fibers in tension for a
submarine the pressure will work to
compress the hull placing the fibers
primarily in compression this
immediately set off alarm bells in my
mind when I heard of the missing
submarine you should absolutely check
out the rest of real engineering's video
on it it's really incredible but he
explains that the carbon fiber is great
for buoyancy in that Rush thought that
this would help the sub float right to
the surface whereas steel and titanium
hulls require foam layers but Rush
wanted to avoid the foam layers to cut
costs this is where things get iffy
Ocean Gate had no idea where there was
up to the task or not and we know this
because they admit it in their own blog
post justifying their decision to not
test the vehicle with a regulatory Body
Ocean Gate's former director of marine
operations David Lockridge wrote a
report in which he concluded that the
craft needed more testing and stressed
the potential dangers to passengers of
the Titan as the submersible reached
extreme depths Lockridge thought that
the carbon fiber Hull would come apart
after repeated Dives Lockridge met with
rush and other company the executives
and laid out his concerns and he also
claimed that the Titan had other
significant design flaws for example the
viewport was only certified to work in
depths up to 1300 meters and to reach
the Titanic the Titan would need to go 4
000 meters under the ocean's surface and
there are private agencies that expect
and certifies submersibles but Lockridge
said that Ocean Gate didn't want to pay
for independent certifications the
company fired Lockridge and then sued
him for disclosing confidential
information Ocean Gate said that
Lockridge was not an engineer and that
the company's own testing of the whole
strength was better than the independent
testing that Lockridge had recommended
but Lockridge was not the only voice
sounding an alarm about the Titan's
design director James Cameron has
designed submersibles himself and
visited the Titanic many times he said
that the carbon fiber construction of
the Titan was quote fundamentally flawed
and that everyone in deep sea
exploration knew about it you know this
is a mature art and many people in the
community were very concerned about this
sub and a number of the top players in
the in the Deep submergence engineering
community even wrote letters to the
company saying that what they were doing
was too experimental to carry passengers
and that needed to be certified and and
so on so and a few months after
Lockridge was fired 38 members of the
manned underwater Vehicles Committee of
the Marine technology Society wrote Rush
a letter stating that in their unanimous
opinion he was misleading the public and
risking a catastrophic outcome quote
your marketing material advertises that
the Titan design will meet or exceed dnv
GL safety standards yet it does not
appear that Ocean Gate has the intention
of following dnvgl class rules your
representations at a minimum are
misleading to the public and breaches an
industry-wide professional code of
conduct we all Endeavor to uphold now
obviously this is an incredibly damning
letter lawyers who file negligence
lawsuits have to prove that the
defendant didn't follow the ordinary
standard of care or worse it knowingly
didn't follow a standard of care and
usually that means hiring an expert
witness in the field who can articulate
the Norms of an industry and evaluate
whether the defendant's conduct met
those norms and in this case we have
experts in the field saying that the
Titan didn't measure up to Industry
standards before the accident even
occurred and the experts concluded that
Rush needed to start with a prototype
that would be validated by Third parties
in order to protect all of these
submersible occupants and in a 2019 blog
post Ocean Gate said quote bringing an
outside entity up to speed on every
Innovation before it's put into real
world testing is anathema to Rapid
Innovation and Rush told Smithsonian
Magazine that the industry was quote
obscenely safe because they have all
these regulations but it also hasn't
innovated or grown because they have all
these regulations so while on the face
of it this looks like the kind of thing
that would be covered by the death on
the high seas act it's actually more
complicated than that because it's not
perfectly clear that the Titan was a
vessel for the purposes of the ACT and
ironically Ocean Gate might be covered
by the same exception to Dosa that White
Star Line used to limit its exposure to
the Titanic disaster itself so let's go
back to 1912 when the Titanic sank off
the coast of Newfoundland in its maiden
voyage the luxury steamship was owned by
White Star Line which bragged that it
was virtually Unsinkable yet as we all
know when the ship set sail it swiftly
ran into an iceberg killing
1517 passengers and it turned out that
the ship had a design flaw the wall
separating the bulkheads extended only a
few feet above the water line so water
could pour in from one of the
compartments into another surviving
family members sought compensation from
wine star line but the company had a
legal trick up its sleeve the limitation
Act of 1851 which was enacted to help
prevent ship owners from going bankrupt
the law gives ship owners the right to
preemptively file a claim in federal
court before plaintiffs have a chance to
sue them the claim limits plaintiffs to
the post-loss value of the vessel and
its cargo if the vessel and cargo were
completely lost the value of the vessel
cannot be calculated in the owner's
Assets in 1915 a judge found that White
Star Line was not guilty and had no
knowledge of the errors that led to the
catastrophic loss and that meant that
they didn't have to compensate the
families for the fatalities and since
the accident was considered the fault of
the Titanic's captain and crew the
company's liability was limited to the
total of Passenger fares the amount paid
for cargo and any Salvage materials that
were recovered from the wreck and the
company settled for 664 thousand dollars
to be divided among the survivors and
the same limitation Act exception might
provide Ocean Gate with a way to avoid
liability since the post-casualty value
of the Titan is basically zero but
there's also another wrinkle to this law
in 2019 a dieboat carrying 33 passengers
and six crew members caught fire and
sank off the coast of California
resulting in the deaths of 34 people
days after the boat sank its owners
filed a limitation action seeking to
limit their liability to the value of
the vessel which was effectively zero in
response Congress enacted the small
passenger vessel Act which carves out
certain small passenger vessels from
being able to limit their liability to
the value of their vessel this is an
exception to the exception and these
smaller vessels can now be held liable
for any and all losses arising from a
maritime casualty and the ACT defines a
small passenger vessel as one carrying
not more than 49 passengers on an
overnight domestic voyage and not more
than 150 passengers on any voyage that
is not an overnight domestic Voyage the
spva could apply to the Titan but the
law is new and has yet to be tested in
court and there are other open questions
like whether a submersible is considered
a vessel for the purposes of the spva
and whether American law would even
apply in the first place because there
are lots of jurisdictional questions too
the United States and Canada have
launched investigations into what
happened to the Titan however it isn't
clear which country would have
jurisdiction over legal claims Ocean
Gate Expeditions the company that owned
and operated the Titan is based in
Everett Washington the company shut down
its Everett operations after the
accident and the Titan was launched from
a ship called the polar Prince which is
flagged from Canada the people on board
the subversible were from England
Pakistan France and the United States
and of course the wreck is in the middle
of the Atlantic now the United States
Coast Guard regulates passenger carrying
submersibles and submersibles with fewer
than six passengers have not been
subject to inspection which is probably
why Stockton Russia's sub carried only
five people U.S regulations State quote
because of the unique design and
operating characteristics as well as the
inherent hazards of underwater operation
an uninspected submersible may be
permitted in U.S passenger operations
only if it is designed and constructed
to a recognized industry standard that
means it's illegal to transport
passengers in a sub that is experimental
Rush classified the passengers as
Mission Specialists and classified their
250 thousand dollar fee as a donation in
order to evade the implication that they
were just ticket buying passengers but
industry experts knew that Stockton was
trying to evade these regulations
William Conan is one of the experts who
signed a letter urging Stockton rush to
follow the rules what they were doing
for tourism would not be allowed in U.S
Waters the Coast Guard would not allow
it it would not be allowed to work in
British Coastal Waters because it would
have required it to be certified same
thing in Canada and then turns out that
they operated in international waters
where no Coast Guard has jurisdiction
well
you found two loopholes
and
let's just say it wasn't very wise and
although the Titan was developed and
built in Washington state the New Yorker
reported that the company's legal
filings said that the sub would be quote
owned by a Bahamian entity will be
registered in the Bahamas and will
operate exclusively outside of the
territorial Waters of the United States
and at this point while we know that
there will be lots of lawsuits we don't
know who's going to have jurisdiction uh
the status of the insurance of the Titan
or of the passengers and we don't know
whether the waiver that they signed will
be enforceable or not but one thing is
for certain Stockton rush really should
have brushed up on his math and science
skills which you can do with today's
sponsor brilliant because brilliant is
the best way to learn math and computer
science interactively a brilliant is an
online learning platform for stem that
replaces lecture videos with Hands-On
interactive lessons it's for Curious
Learners both young and old professional
and inexperienced and you can quickly
learn to Ace your high school or college
math courses or just learn stuff that
you always wanted to learn brilliant
helps you reach your goals whether you
are a student or a professional looking
to get ahead for example able their new
how technology Works course teaches you
the inner workings of everyday
technology from video compression GPS to
computer memory and another one of my
favorite courses is all about logic
Brilliance logic courses cover liar and
Truth teller riddles logical fallacies
machine logic and even some strategic
game theory logic is of course a
critical skill that lawyers need every
day and Brilliant lets you learn by
doing rather than listening to hours of
boring lectures it's all interactive and
fun you can sign up and start learning
for free today by going to brilliant.org
legaleagle or by clicking on the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description if you click on that
link you'll get a free 30-day trial plus
the first 200 people to sign up will get
20 off their annual subscription so by
clicking on the link below you'll get a
free 30-day trial and 20 off your annual
subscription to brilliant after that
click on this link over here for more
legal eagle or I'll see you in court